him so look that this is the game that
they play this is the life that they've
chosen
sometimes you get the truth sometimes
you don't it's always better
strategically to conceal the truth
sometimes the truth is so obvious it
doesn't hurt you
to admit it chris and that's what
happened yesterday with washington coach
ron rivera on their quarterback plan
here he is talking about what we all
know
that they don't know who their
quarterback's going to be so they're
keeping
all options open well the biggest thing
guys
is we're going to continue to look we're
we're going through this process
you know for agency starts next week the
draft is in uh
in 50 days i understand so uh you know
we still have time
and we're going to continue to to
explore
all the options that are out there i i
think you know you guys
i get it you guys want to answer but we
don't have answers for you right now
because
uh we're still working through the
process again we've got a lot of time
you know with free agency next week and
the draft in 50 days
yeah and he's absolutely right and and
this is a case where
there's nothing that you lose
strategically by acknowledging the
obvious that you don't know who your
quarterback's going to be
you're looking at all the options and
you're going to make a decision at the
appropriate time
now could that hurt them if they haven't
acquired a quarterback
when they're on the clock in round one
is there a flag there hey you better
jump this team if you want to get one of
these quarterbacks that's still sliding
down the board yes that could hurt them
and they may have to trade up
if there's a guy that they really like
to make sure they get him but
they they are are a a clean slate at
quarterback yeah they have kyle allen
yeah they have taylor heinecke neither
guy is the long-term answer they're
still looking for the long-term answer
and maybe they get their long-term
answer this year maybe they get it next
year right i think the one thing they
learned
from the dwayne haskins misadventures
don't just grab whoever's out there
because you feel like you need a
quarterback for the next 15 years no i
agreed on that and you know also
we look at the makeup of your football
team you know you got a lot of other
things to where you can
you can like they showed last year you
can win games still
without a high you know or a
upper tier type of quarterback you know
they had
low level quarterback play last year
even with alex smith it's a great story
but it wasn't like he was bringing
anything special to the game he just
wasn't messing the game up
so for that reason they don't have to
panic you know if they can get a guy in
there
who's just you know again somewhat of a
game manager and can make a play here or
there
you know their offensive line pretty
damn good it looks like they got a
running back they need another receiver
to go with terry mclaren and of course
we know the defense
you know they're they're looking like
they've got a defense that's you know
almost going to be able to win games by
themselves in a lot of
in certain weeks against certain teams
uh so i am interested to see where they
go because they're a team
also though where you look at it and you
go they get a receiver
and if they got a real good quarterback
you'd go whoa
watch out for washington this year and
there's kind of sitting in no man's land
as far as the draft at 19. to me
hey i think the top three will be gone
of course zach wilson lawrence
mack jones kellen mohn from texas a m
i you know i like him mike i like him a
lot and he knows how to
not turn the ball over and do those type
of things he did it this year
so i don't know if they'd go that way
but i think he's worthy of playing the
kind of ball
that alex smith played and what ron
rivera would want would be
an accurate passer he's not going to
take stupid chances
and whoa he's got a rifle for a right
arm and can make some big time plays
with that arm so
i'd look at that uh but but yeah i'm
interested to see if they maybe got one
of these free agents that are out there
too
one guy that we know won't be the
quarterback alex smith even though he
was 5-1 as a starter last year some of
the stuff rivera said yesterday
basically confirming things that alex
smith said they weren't
thrilled with the idea of him playing
again i think they felt the way we felt
right
i got as nervous watching alex smith
play as i did watching my son play in
high school yeah every snap
every time he had the ball every moment
i i was
i how do you wipe that out of your mind
and it just shows
what a testament it is to his his grit
his toughness
courage his drive that he did it because
he's the one who's living
it and everybody else is just like my
gosh how in the world is he doing it so
i can understand what washington was
thinking and it makes me wonder will
there be a team out there
that is really interested in alex smith
uh other than
as a backup because they don't want to
put him on the field and even as a
backup you may have to put him on the
field our team's comfortable doing that
there may be
some teams that say yeah we we see
plenty of reasons to have him
but there's one big reason to not happen
we don't wanna have to worry about this
guy being on the field and having
another serious injury i i think it
it would scare me and again i don't know
i'm rooting for alex smith
he's awesome guy but i mean just as a
pure football
business if i was a gm pro personnel guy
that would scare me to death there's no
other way i can really say that
now hey going back to truthful coaches
though
see ron rivera never bses you
you never and that's where i love ron
rivera yeah we're 50 whatever days
something we don't know our quarterback
yet
yeah yeah uh everything alex smith said
there and then interview
it's pretty true you know so you know
that i love about ron i think that's why
players like ron
and what it also was gonna do is that
one day he wants to play coy and be
you know johnny politician and say one
thing it's gonna hold some water hold
some weight to where you're gonna go
well ron's never really he tells the
truth every time
they're not really interested in that
guy and then whoa they are they got them
the next day or whatever that is
it does it is that way or at least
there's some value in the way that ron
rivera handles himself and i respect
that about him a lot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports